so this session is called master the art
of the ast but before we explain what an
ASD or an abstract syntax tree is let's
talk about why it's an art form that we
would want to master so if you're using
javascript today you're obviously using
a lot of tools and maybe you've even
heard about this expression called
JavaScript fatigue where you have to
learn these tools but I would argue that
the real frustration comes once you've
begun to rely on these tools and you
find that they fail you there is some
breaking point but we're gonna see that
more often than not there's something
you can do about it to solve this
problem yourself and we're going to demo
that today by solving these three
problems today together so we're gonna
see how you can write your own linting
rules to enforce your team's conventions
how you can write your own transpiling
logic and how you can write code mods or
code modification scripts that will
allow you to do a large-scale
refactoring very quickly and with
confidence these are the three tools
that solve these problems today in the
JavaScript ecosystem you have es lint as
a linter babble as a transpiler and
facebook's JS code shift as a codemod
runner now other than the fact that
these are open source tools on the web
which means of course you can go and get
hub and read their source code which
unique about these three tools is that
they were all developed with this idea
for a plug-in based architecture so that
means that the original tool creators
went to a lot of trouble to let you
extend these tools and give them new
capabilities without having to
understand exactly all of the internals
of how they work now personally the one
that I got started with is es lint es n
comes with about 250 built in very
powerful very well tested rules but I
thought that they the behavior that I
was getting from one of them I
considered it to be a bug so I did what
you normally do when you encounter a bug
I went on github I opened up an issue
and I waited very payed with patience
for one of the maintainer x' at their
earlier convenience to kind of give me a
response and so I was able to wait for
about ten minutes and then I decided to
go on their chatroom and start hunting
down one of the maintained
to give me an answer and despite the
fact that was pretty pushy they were
very friendly and what they explained to
me is that this behavior that I'm
describing what I consider to be a bug
is not really a bug as they see it but
what's unique about innocent and kind of
what makes it different than previous
JavaScript lenders that came before is
that they really encourage you to write
your own rule and it's meant to be
extend extensible and so they pointed me
to the docs explaining exactly how to
create your own rule and I learned that
in order to create an es net rule I have
to learn these two concepts so a estie's
abstract syntax trees and the visitor
pattern it wasn't very difficult and
after kind of learning the basis of it I
was able to write my own e essential
which became a part of our build chain
and now whenever whenever somebody
violated this convention the build would
break we would catch it early and fix it
fast forward a few months later I wanted
to write my own babble plugin and to my
surprise I didn't have to learn any new
concepts because babble plugins also
rely on a STS and the visitor pattern
and as you can guess my now the same
thing happened when I wanted to write my
own code mod as well so that's why we'd
only 30 minutes left to this talk we're
going to be able to get all this done
and learn the basis of extending these
tools so they're no longer a black box
and instead something that you can open
up and tinker with but ASDs are not
unique to just these three tools pretty
much any tool in JavaScript ecosystem
that you're using today that needs to
read javascript or output JavaScript
does so by manipulating and analyzing
AST s so it's a worthy skill to have a
bit about me my name is Yana Tamara I'm
a front-end tech lead at Sears Israel
where our mission is to reinvent the
online and mobile shopping experience
okay so what are abstract syntax trees
simply put an abstract syntax tree is
your original source code represented as
a tree data structure but let's see an
example that will clarify this so here I
have pretty much the shortest piece of
JavaScript code I can think of and it's
matching ast representation let's take a
look at the code and the ast and kind of
figure out why they match
so you have a an assignment var foo
equals the string bar and your ASD is
always starts out as a root node called
the program node which has the body
which is just a list of all the
statements in your code each statement
would have its own node in this case we
only have one statement so variable
declaration which is composed of the
kind that's that left hand part var and
you have the variable declaration aim of
the variable in this case the identifier
foo and the value of the assignment
which in this case since it's a
hard-coded string anything that's
hard-coded the name of the node that
relates to it is called a literal node
so this should make it a bit clearer but
let's see if we can even improve on this
and make it clearer so this is the exact
same ast but represented as a JSON
object and as developers I'm sure this
is a lot more nice to look at one thing
to notice about the JSON representation
is that each of the nodes always has
this type property so the there is a set
list of available types that you can
have in a valid ast that describes valid
JavaScript and you kind of have to learn
the properties of each one but you never
have to really memorize it and we're
gonna see why not in a minute but do
notice that if you know the type of the
property sorry the type of the node that
you're on then you can know which other
properties it's gonna have and then you
can understand how to read that to note
there are four steps we have when we're
working with a STS and we're gonna go
over each one well actually if you're
only writing a tool that needs to just
read JavaScript and it doesn't have to
output JavaScript you can only get away
with just using the first year so the
PAR step the PAR step is all about
taking your original source code and
converting it into an AST there are
several open source parsers online and
what they all share is that they expose
a parse function that takes the string
which is your original source code and
returns a JavaScript object which is the
AST now for the examples that we're
gonna take a look at today you don't
have to choose a parser because all the
tools that I mentioned already chose one
is default which just works but you can
actually in most cases swap it
for a different parser if you think you
need to do it this is a great resource
if you're only remember one resource on
this talk make it this one to get
started with the ASD tinkering it's
called ASD xplornet
and it's a similar tool to kind of J's
bin or or a code pen that lets you like
play with code online and what you can
do is you can just type JavaScript on
the left and it'll show you the matching
ast on the right and it's interactive so
if I have if I have a lot of code here I
can click on the line on the left hand
side it'll take me to the matching node
on the right hand side and I can also
hover over nodes here and it'll
highlight the relevant parts in the code
in the left hand part so this is why you
never have to memorize the set list of
available types because you can always
just paste in some code here similar to
the problem that you're trying to solve
and be familiarized again with what the
type of node is called and what
properties does it have so this is just
a parser online ready for you to play
with now let's talk about the Traverse
step why do we need to traverse our ast
if we're reading JavaScript we're gonna
we're trying to analyze something about
that JavaScript and we only care about
some elements or some attributes of our
code not all of them that means that we
first need to find the nodes that we
care about that we care about to solve
whatever problem it is we're trying to
solve so let's talk about the Traverse
step in the context of the first problem
that we're gonna solve today together
and that's writing your own es Lynch
rule let's see the example that I told
you about earlier the one that I got
started with so first the problem and
then the rule that solves this problem
we're gonna be talking about something
called code piggybacking and don't worry
if you haven't heard of it because I
just made it up recently so this is
pegged piggybacking if you're not a
familiar with it when you stand on
somebody's shoulders you don't have to
have an actual Pig involved but let's
see what piggybacking looks like in code
so here I have years then hooked up to
my editor so I get this nice integration
here and it's showing me
something is wrong this is one of the
built-in yes Nik rules that catches any
variable that's not defined so it wasn't
there was no var statement saying that
there's a variable called Acme it's not
a function parameter it wasn't imported
via an import statement it's just
something that's assumed to be globally
available even though it's not it's
clearly something that we just made up
so this works as expected
but what surprised me is watch what
happens when I do this I changed
Acme to be a property of the window
object and because window is whitelisted
because the iStent knows that I'm
writing browser code so console is
whitelisted that window is white listed
it doesn't check anything beyond that
point but if you're writing browser code
you know that anything that's a global
variable is also a property of window so
in terms of the runtime implications of
this it's exactly the same and yet yes
it goes north ignores this completely
when Acme starts to piggyback on typos
on window so that's the problem that
we're trying to solve because without
this people will be able to commit code
like this and in runtime this variable
might be undefined and such so let's see
how the rule that solves this works this
applies to this rule but also to any iya
central this the structure is the same
so an ESN rule is a node script where I
have to return an object the properties
of the object their name has to match
one of the known ast valid types and the
function that we pass in as the value
will be called for each node of that
type as we traverse our tree but let's
figure out why what we need to input
here for our own rule so we care about
cases where it's window dot something
where that something is not a valid
global but if we zoom out a bit we're
first we need to find all nodes that are
just of the type something that's
something right food bar a dot B so we
go on a SD explorer and we pay something
like that and we wait till both are
highlighted and we can see that the name
of the type is called a member
expression and a member expression will
always have an object property which is
that left-hand part and you can see it's
highlighting it and the right-hand part
is referred to as the property
so this is why in our rule that solves
this problem we're gonna write member
expression here now this function will
be called for any member expression in
our code but we don't care about all
member expressions we just care about
the ones where the object is window and
property the right-hand part is
something that's not a valid global
property we're going to see how that
helper function is implemented in a
minute but assuming that this condition
is correct and I already found the piece
the piece of code that that essentially
means that somebody is piggybacking on
top of window and this is something that
I want to report to catch early so ESA
it exposes this context that report
method and I can pass in whatever error
message that I want and this is how this
helper function is implemented esn't
also analyzes scope on your behalf so it
exposes this variables array and already
prepopulates it with anything that's in
scope in the environment you're running
under so when you as a user configure
your scent you tell it are you writing a
browser code are you writing a node and
it will pre populate that with the known
Global's in that environment so for a
browser this would be a document and
window and console etc and it as they
would iterate through this note it would
see that there in our particular case
there is no Acme variable and that's why
it will tell us that this is in fact an
invalid global so let's see this in
action this is again yes then it
integrated with the editor and my silly
little piggybacking error message gets
the seal of approval because it looks
very nice when you get the integration
with the sn8 like that yeah so ES
Central's custom rules they you can
support anything that one of the
built-in es Ihnen rules does now without
knowing we use something called the
visitor pattern here just the fact that
I didn't have to tell you since how to
traverse a valley tree how to go from
the root node all the way to the bottom
nodes
I only had to tell it which kind of
nodes I care about and give that
callback function to be called for each
node of that type that's making use of
the visitor pattern and that's going to
come in handy in the next example
as well now let's talk about a tool that
needs to output JavaScript as well and
it does so by manipulating the ASD of
the original javascript file the most
well-known tool that does this is babble
babble started out as a project called
65 and its main objective was to let you
write es6 and compile it down to es 5
which can run on any browser but they
realize that the problem that they
solved is more generic so they rebranded
as Babel and they went into a lot of
trouble so that it's now based on this
plugin based architecture and you can
extend it by writing different plugins
the example that I'm going to show now
is actually is one of the built-in Babel
plugins but I chose it just because it's
very simple but helps to get the message
across but a third party plug-in would
also behave the same way so first the
problem that we're trying to solve you
might be familiar with the debugger
statement in JavaScript if not it's just
a keyword that lets you trigger a
breakpoint immediately from code and
it's great for development but it's not
something that you would want to ship to
production because under some
circumstances it could actually be
triggered for your users and then your
entire app would freeze so as part of
preparing our code for production as
part of us using Babel we can choose to
get just get rid of it completely so if
i run babel it will produce the
distribution version of this file and it
would be the exact same code only the
debugger statement is gone now let's see
how its implemented so this should look
familiar to the esn't example a babel
plugin is just a node script where we
return an object and here it's even
wrapped inside this visitor objects
which reminds us that we're using the
visitor pattern but the same rule
applies so we need to figure out what's
the name of the type of node that we
care about which again we can use ast
Explorer for we just type debugger I see
that since debugger is a reserved
keyword it also has a reserved node ast
type all on its own which is called
debugger statement
and for any debugger statement in my
code I can call path dot remove which is
essentially modifying and manipulating
the ast and removing that node from the
code of course you can apply some custom
logic here do some other conditional
checks but for our example if we find
the debugger statement we just want to
get rid of it completely regardless now
let's talk about the generating code
step the generating code step is kind of
the reverse of the PAR step right the
power step was all about converting our
code from from just a source string into
an ast now we have our modified ast and
we want to regenerate it back into code
now you implicitly have to make some
choices when you're generating code from
the ast are you using tabs or are using
spaces windows line endings or Linux
style line endings when we are using
something like babel we don't really
care about which one we're going to use
because babel code babel code is
typically just throwaway code right you
regenerate it every time that you push
the production and during development
maybe even every time you hit save but
now we're going to see a case where
we're going to need to be a bit smarter
with the mechanism we use when we
generate code that's the case with J's
code shift J's code shift is a framework
by Facebook which tries to solve the
problems of doing very large-scale very
tedious refactoring we're doing so
manually would be very time-consuming
and potentially error-prone so what it
lets you do is it lets you write
something called a codemod code
modification script that describes how
you want to change your original source
code and it will iterate through your
files and change it accordingly so
essentially it means that you're gonna
let machines write code for you is there
anyone here who already dismissed this
because he thinks this is a terrible
idea and it would be super buggy and
never let machines write code for you so
this was my initial reaction at first so
what I would say that that is that you
should be skeptical you should
definitely understand the implications
of running letting a machine write code
for you you should test it very well and
you should understand all kind of edge
cases that
that you might have missed initially
it's not something you just run push the
production go home
so skepticism in this case is healthy
but this has merit it's all a trade-off
of is it more time-consuming to test the
codemod very thoroughly composed to
doing them refactoring manually so what
are the type of things we can use J's
coach if for well kind of the most
well-known thing that people are using
this for is for doing something that's
kind of the reverse of what we use Babel
for when we're using Babel we typically
do it to convert from the newer
JavaScript syntax down to older syntax
that can run on any browser but what if
we have a large code base that was
written long before the days of es6 es 7
es 8 and we want to start adopting these
latest best practices for example what
if we want to get rid of all our boring
old var statements and turn them into
shiny new LED statements let's see one
option of how you can try to tackle this
with a code model so in this code mod
what we do again a node script we here
we need to actually explicitly parse our
code but J's co-chief does it so J is
just a wrapper around the J's code shift
API we pass in file dot source and we
get root which is the root node of our
ast which contains the entire ast we're
doing something similar to the visitor
pattern but no longer with the this
object syntax so here we just call root
dot find and we tell it which kind of
node we want to find because we're
trying to get to do something on all
variable declarations defined with var
we pass in variable declaration kind've
are again variable declaration you can
find that out on a SD explorer then we
pass in the function that will be called
for each node of that type and inside
what we want to do is create a new
variable declaration pretty similar to
the previous one
that's that people're but different in a
way that now it's defined as a let
statement now this is just an object in
memory so the next thing we do to
actually change the ast is we swap them
out with the replace with method and the
last thing we do is we call route to
source now remember we're talking about
in the context of the generate code step
what j/s co-chief does when it
regenerates our ast into code is it
tries to understand everything about the
original code style that we were using
so are using spaces or using tabs and it
will try to change as little as possible
about the source file because it's not
writing a new file it's actually
overwriting your original file what this
means is that when we go into our git
source control whatever a diff window
before we commit this we're going to be
able to see exactly what changed and it
will make it a lot easier to pick up on
potential bugs introduced in this code
speaking of bugs introduced by this code
mod does anybody have a problem with
this code I'm not sure if there are no
hands up I'm not seeing them but you
might have noticed that the what I did
here has actually turned any LED
statements or any var statement into a
LED statement now var and let aren't
interchangeable there's a reason that we
have this new LED keyword right it means
something different var declarations are
function scoped and let declarations are
block scoped so that means that we can't
just change it like that we have to
check how the variable is used because
if before we were to define the variable
with var inside a scope and use it
outside of the scope it might have been
like smelly frowned upon but it would
still work and now it would actually be
a syntax error because let enforces it
so that you can't use the variable
outside of the scope or was defined the
good news is is that there is a better
code mod that solves this a bit longer
more lines of code it's open source on
the web created by Christophe nakazawa
and it's called no VARs code mod and it
does this switch intelligently so it
checks how the variable is used and it
will even promote it all the way up from
var to Const if it can let's try to see
it in action
so here I'm just calling the J's code
shift command line tool and I'm telling
it to use the no VARs transformation on
this repo what it will do it it will
spawn different child processes just so
that if your code base is indeed very
large it would do so very quickly and
sorry and if I go in and see the changes
I can see that all my original VAR
statements most of them are now con
statements but in some cases like here
we can see that one of these variables I
guess was being reassigned to so it was
only way able to promote it all the way
up to a let's statement this repo isn't
one of mine actually what I did is I
went on the global issue search on
github and I looked for people who maybe
aren't familiar with the fact that you
can do this type of refactoring very
easily with code mods and I looked for
any open issues that want to replace var
with let and I found this one this
person wrote it's a thousand seventeen
use that instead of var or at least
that's kind of the tone of that I'm
imagining in my head when I'm reading
this and well I love about this also is
that this was open in 2016
so now we'll pray to the Wi-Fi gods and
try to commit this
and we can open up a pull request
so it's really that easy now I trust
this code mob because I've used it
before and I trust the person who wrote
it and it's well tested but yeah it's
not something that you would definitely
do as quickly like that but once you
have confidence in your code mod it
can't be that easy thank you very much
this repo up here on the top contains a
bunch of links related to getting
started with ASDs so if you want to get
started this will be something that I
would recommend and also feel free to
reach out to me on Twitter I have open
DMS you can ask me tell me if you're
getting stuck I'll be more than happy to
help you out as well as here at the
conference thank you very much
[Applause]